at least five police officers have been
killed in the latest violence of a
deadly gang war that is gripping Ecuador
Tuesday explosive devices went off in
the port city of Guayaquil and in the
city of esmeraldas including an attack
on a health center officials blamed
organized crime for the attacks as
retaliation for the transfer of hundreds
of gang members from violent and
overcrowded prisons to other detention
centers
the gang members oppose the transfers
in a video published on social media
several prison guards appear to have
been taken as hostages the men were seen
with explosive tied to their bodies
heavily armed gang members declared war
against the government from inside the
prison
if you don't return our people to the
Pavilion we will start bombing bus
stations Bridges wherever there are
innocent people and you will be
responsible for their deaths in response
president Guillermo lasso has declared a
45 days long state of emergency in two
provinces with a curfew at 9pm every
night
these sabotage and terrorism acts are a
declaration of war against the rule of
law we will not allow it
earlier this week two headless bodies
were left dangling from a pedestrian
bridge control of the lucrative cocaine
Market is fueling much of the violent
gang Warfare in recent years Ecuador has
increasingly become a Transit point for
drugs destined to the United States and
Europe which has brought an escalation
of violence in cities like Guayaquil as
state forces tried to stop criminal
organizations linked to the
international drug cartels some analysts
say the government is losing control of
entire provinces in a country that had
never seen this level of violence before
growing and criminal organizations feel
much more emboldened to display their
violent rituals because they know they
will likely not be arrested or if they
are arrested they will not be prosecuted
police have arrested at least 28 people
in response to this week's attacks and
seized thousands of explosives this year
Ecuador forces have confiscated record
amounts of cocaine and arrested hundreds
of alleged gang members but their
operations have done little to bring
relief to areas now dominated by fear
Alessandra Al jazeeran